Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
April 30th. And I just slammed the
fucking mixer now. Everything's too quiet.
Hello? Hello? Hello my
baby. Hello my honey.
Where the fuck have you
Ben? You fucking whole. Ah,
it's fucking 2:00 AM. Um, what's up?
How are Ya? I'm back from, um,
I'm back from the east
coast back from east coast.
I did a wonderful Gig at the University
of conquered in Concord, New Hampshire.
I had an awesome time Warner.
Thank everybody who came
out. I had a great time.
And um, um, I don't know what to tell you.
It's been a while since I did a college
gig. It was actually cool because it was,
it was open to the public. Usually
when they have college gigs, they,
they're not open to the public in case
you were wondering case you didn't
understand when I said usually they're
not open to the public the first time or
whatever the fuck I said, I don't know
what I just said. But usually it's just,
it's just all going to be students,
students,
and then a couple of crabby
teachers hanging in the
background or maybe some rat
have a student who's going to sit there
and wait for you to say something,
you know,
and then write about it and blog about it.
And the next thing you know you're
on good Mary. Good Morning America,
Good Morning America, right?
Who pitched that fucking show?
I mean God knows it's a hit,
but Jesus Christ. How do you,
how did you pitch that name
of for a show without either,
without like either
snickering as you said,
the name of the show or having
your balls pull up inside of you.
I want to do is show
nationally syndicated edits.
It starts at six in the morning and it's
called Good Morning America Gun Marnie
in America. Why would you do that? And we,
I just want to sit there and
be pleasant for three hours.
Do you know who took them meeting
with somebody the other day? Yes.
I just said that.
That's how Hollywood I am.
I took a meeting and by taking a meeting,
I mean I went out and I got a fucking
Omelet, sat across from somebody,
see it like fucking toast
between the teeth is and um,
I dunno. I, I don't, I don't
think, I don't think it's
ever going to happen for me.
People. I think I'm going
to be like Willie Nelson.
I think I'm going to be on
the road my whole life, man.
I gotta tell you got tell you what
I got that freedom in my bones,
man. I fucked up. You know what I mean?
I fucked up in my career.
How did you fuck up bill?
I stayed out there too long.
You know,
like that 43 year old
guy still in the clubs,
shocking in his gut with the button down
shiny shirt, still hitting on the lady,
right. Teeth are already
starting to discolor, you know,
cause you so old,
no matter how much you brush him,
they still just,
after a while you just can't keep
up with the, the red wine tied.
It just keeps turning your
teeth just a little grayer.
And, uh, I stayed out on
the road too long. I did.
I was a standup comic for too
long. I fucked up. I fucked up.
And now I don't know how to work with
other people because for 20 years it's
been, hey, here's an idea. And then I go,
yeah, I agree with that. You know why?
Because it's my idea. I totally
agree with that shit. And now,
now all of a sudden I'm coming in from,
from the fucking Bush,
right after 20 goddamn tours and now I
got to sit here and try and work with
other people.
I don't know how to do it.
I really shouldn't be
saying this on my podcast.
I don't know how to fucking do it.
Okay.
You know, we saw your
tape. We really liked it.
We thought that you were, you have really
mainstream sort of comedy. Uh, yeah.
I really don't think it's mainstream. I
say con to every other word. Yeah, I know,
but, but there's a main
stream sensibility to it.
And I'm literally sitting there going,
all right,
this is an argument and fucking six weeks.
Right. Got It. I'm in
what I'm talking about.
What the fuck was I going with that?
Oh, let, let, let's, let's, let's rewind.
We weren't, we weren't New Hampshire.
Beautiful Goddamn state by the way.
And the people aren't as simple as
they try to make them every year,
every four years.
You know,
when there's a presidential election
and he do that little quaint piece above
the primary,
Zoe started rolling.
Okay.
Stay called New Hampshire and then
down to earth, kind of flat to people.
Whenever they say salt of the
earth down to earth, that's there.
That's there a euphemism for calling
you retarded. You know what I mean?
There really is sort of a media bias
where if you don't live in New York or La,
you're just considered a fucking moron.
You know what I mean?
All those God damn shows you just,
you just a fucking moron.
All the God damn TV shows,
you know,
there's always the smart person who moved
from New York or some major city back
to their hometown and everybody
there is a fucking retard. Right?
But, um, I don't know. Maybe
there's some fucking truth to it.
Who the hell knows. So anyways, I'm up in
Concord, New Hampshire, beautiful state,
lush state, plenty of trees, plenty
of water, plenty of game and fish,
you know, plenty of fatties, right?
Their food source,
they're already Mabo Day.
If you think about that,
when you look,
when you think about yourself as
like what kind of shape you're in,
like if someone was to
throw you on a grill,
like what kind of steak would you be?
You know, would you be a lean cut
of meat? You know, make a Philemon,
Yana would you be a fucking
New York strip? A goddamn
buy,
one of those John Candy steaks.
I gotta tell you I've been on the
fucking road a little bit. Uh,
and you know what it is? I take my special
and then I was just like, well fuck it.
I can get fat again cause I don't got to
worry about being on TV for another two
years. So I started eating
Sundays. What else did he,
I just started having lunches like you
did when you were in the seventh grade.
You know, there's like a bag of
Fritos and a soda and some sort of a,
some sort of protein with somehow
in there. Right. So Braid, um,
and he was, I'm, I'm trying to dance
around this fucking subject, but, uh,
the Bruins lost Bruins lost.
There's nothing like,
there's nothing like, I don't
know, losing an overtime sucks,
but, uh, I don't know what it is about
hockey. Hockey's just so fucking,
it just, it killed you, right? So we lose,
but I gotta be honest with the capital's
would definitely be a better team.
I felt that there was a better team,
pretty much every game.
This Guy Kevin Dupont for the Boston
Globe wrote a great article or he just
basically summed up the series where
they just were always a little better,
a little quicker. It had a little better
defense, a little bit of fore checking,
just a little better everything.
So they deserve it. Fucking pricks.
Um, so then what happens, right?
The overtime golf people aren't,
hockey fans were scored by
a guy who was not white.
He was not Asian. I was a black guy,
scored the goal. Right. So then like,
you know, it's game seven, it's in Boston.
Boston loses. So right. Then
you know what's going to happen?
All the fucking racist
coming out of the woodwork,
they texts like Goddamn a
hundred of those things.
Just calling the guy the n word,
like you're talking like,
like shit that they would cut out of
the script and like Mississippi burning
going like, all right, you know
what? That's too fucking harsh.
So I started getting all these emails
going through what's up with all the
racist Boston fans and Blahblahblah
trashing me and I'm like, oh,
isn't this hilarious? You know,
this is hilarious. You have,
so basically you're not
supposed to judge all by a few,
but it's okay to do it in this direction.
So I'm on my fucking high horse, right?
So I go back to Boston, just so happens
this weekend and I'm hanging out.
One night I'd have off in Boston,
and I hate to admit it,
I heard the n word twice.
I heard it alluded to another time.
And I just finally had the, I
had to fucking go home. You know,
I'm not saying it's worse than Alabama,
but I don't think it's any better.
Just fucking brutal.
Granted,
I did go to a moron bar. It was
the gene pool I was in, but I,
I, you know, I can't defend
it. I can't defend it anymore.
It's fucking embarrassing. Um, I dunno.
Just fucking embarrassing.
Good Morning America.
How are you? All right, let's
get on with the fucking, uh,
and unbelievably ignorant too. You
know, I just fucking, I, I just, I,
for the life of me,
uh,
I don't get it. One of the guys had a
lazy eye too. That's what killed me.
Okay.
You know, it's like, dude,
have you looked in a two
mirrors simultaneously and
seeing what you're looking
at? How the fuck are you looking
down on anybody? No, no, no. What,
so now I've got to trash people,
Lazy eyes to get my point across that
I don't appreciate racist people.
I'm a fucking idiot myself. But
you know what? I'm going to,
I'm doing something about it.
Unlike those morons,
I ran two back in my fucking
embarrassing city over the weekend. Um,
I'm sick of not having a
good science background.
So I actually went to a bookstore and
one of the few remaining bookstores out
there and,
uh,
I bought a book on how to rebuild a
carburetor and I also bought a book on the
elements. It's hilarious.
It's this big giant book.
Um, I'm, I'm, my mind is already blown
cause this shit is like magic to me.
Telling me that my foot,
that'd be things made out of matter.
What the fuck did it say? The
Earth, this book, your foot,
everything is tangible.
Everything tangible is made of elements.
Your foot is made mostly of oxygen
with quite a bit of carbon. Joining it,
giving it structure to the organic
molecules that define you as an example of
carbon based life. I was like,
that just fucking blew my mind.
I didn't know it was carbon and me.
Carbon fiber.
I don't know what carbon fiber,
what do they do?
Isn't it like even in bulletproof
vests, this a dumb idea. I have no idea.
So then I'm sitting there going,
so does that mean you can kind of
shoot me in the foot? You know,
with some sort of low caliber gun and
it's going to ricochet off or if it goes
through,
does all the air come out?
I just don't get it. I don't
fucking get it. All right.
I've gone on these fucking websites.
I try and read about how a plane flies.
I swear to God, Wikipedia. It's
hilarious. Like you know when you,
when you're reading about trying to
figure out how to God damn plane flies,
they have a,
you know, they'll have whatever.
They'll have like, you know,
two pages on the shit basically explained
and how's it goes down in like every
paragraph has like two words highlighted
in case you don't know what that means.
And I would have to click on every word.
So I'll click on a word and
then they start to define that.
And then it's the same thing.
It's another page of shit.
Wherever you paragraph does
three more things highlighted.
And then I've got to click on that thing
and I had just keep getting further and
further away from how
the fucking plane flies.
And I get all the way down to
like page one of Wikipedia.
God Damn like you.
No scratch and sniff picture with some
lady with like a sock puppet. Tronics
let's just, let's just start
really, really slow, Bill.
I'm sick of it. All right.
Um, I think there's something,
I don't know what's going on with my
truck. It hesitates in first gear,
first gear. So I thought it
was a clutch. Someone else's,
it could be the clutch will or
we could be in yet cabaret rater.
So I start reading up on carburetors,
right? And the whole fucking,
the whole philosophy create a vacuum
and in, in whatever that word is,
when you turn a liquid
into a Goddamn mist.
And at the end of it,
I'm just looking at this angle and this
is just a bunch of fucking screws and
springs, you know, why don't
we just go to the junk yard,
get one,
take it apart and put it back together
and just keep reading these fucking books
and eventually at some
point it has to click right.
So that's what I'm doing.
I went on Ebay because I'm too fucking
lazy because I'm a fucking Hollywood
phony.
Rather than go down to a salvage Yad,
you know I'm going to fucking just go
on Ebay and bid on some old carburetor
that's going to be a fight.
When that thing shows up,
it's going to be a little box and he is
going to see it and think I bought her
something nice. Oh, it has a lot of way to
it. It's going to be expensive. I would.
Or if it's shiny and it's
just going to open it up,
there's going to be some old fucking
old ass carburetor, you know? I Dunno.
You guys at least give me points
for trying. Does that work?
How about Paul Versey last week,
everybody who became a father again today,
congratulation to New Jersey's own, Paul
Versey and a beautiful baby girl today.
Uh, how about how much did he
kill it last week? You know,
people eat be the most people,
90% of people love them.
And then there was people who weren't
into sports and they thought it was like
the worst podcast ever. I had some
fucking Douche bag from across the way.
Uh, I dunno where it was over in
Europe or something. And he goes,
why don't you just call your podcast
a sports podcast? Just see, no,
you're losing all of your
foreign listeners, right?
Like he speaks for all a fucking Swahili.
I hate when people do that shit.
And it was one fucking God damn podcast.
And I talked about sports
every fucking podcast.
Alright, you selfish cunt.
I'll fucking unfunny.
Are the people in your country that
you have to go all the way across the
Atlantic Ocean to find a podcast
to listen to you jackass.
Let me tell you something.
A person from another country
don't fucking threaten me.
The right you can't. I don't give a
fuck if you listen to this and not.
I really don't.
So send me fucking Twitter messages like,
like I'm sitting here shaking.
All right,
I don't need you to
continue to make no money.
You ever thought about that
fucking Sydney of buying used carburetors
can sit there and threaten me like
you're taking something away from me.
Go fuck yourself with your wooden shoes.
Huh?
What do you live in Greece or something?
You're mad at me cause you
fucking economy. What the
hell is going on over there?
I don't understand how that whole thing
collapsed. Everybody rioted and a,
but still the,
everybody is still fine.
You know people are eating and they're
not happy, but you know they're out there.
That you Kevin a, a Greek salad. Did
they call it a Greek salad over there?
Did he just say, let me get
a salad. You know? Oh like a,
like, let's like in a, in Philly,
they're going, let me get a cheese steak.
They don't go, let me get a Philly.
Let me get a Philadelphia cheese steak.
Let me get a steak.
Um,
I want to still been with
fucking cheese was Jesus Christ,
nor do people so fat and ugly
and that Goddamn city. Huh? Um,
they one the other day, right?
Philadelphia is a big wind. Danny Briere.
It's the only time I've ever seen a
guy scored two goals in one overtime.
Okay.
You did the impossible. First
time he did it, he was a cheetah.
You know,
there was a kicking motion.
I was in a bar actually
drinking when that happened.
Listening to people say racist things to
me, dawn is bad enough that they lost.
But then the guy who scored it
was like fucking insult to injury.
You know what I'm saying?
Kid? And I was like,
what are you one of those fucking racist
on Twitter? Oh, no, no, don't, don't.
I'm just, you know, I'm just
saying, I like when people do that.
They fucking backtrack the ignorance
of what people were saying to me.
Yeah, dude, you hear
about showing show? Yeah.
I got two fucking kids and
then his wife went gay.
Swear to God, direct
quote, his wife went gay.
She fucking abroad now fucking shocks kid
went gay. Um, you know, like, like you,
I went to the star, then I went to
the post office and then I went gay.
That's, that's what happens. There's
a little, there's a store down there,
a little homosexuality store
that you can go to. Um,
fuck jaw droppingly stupid.
Not saying everybody.
The irony is that Harvard is there. That's
the funny thing at MIT and all that.
You know, Boston has this weird
fucking sort of like, you know,
couple people who are really smart
and then the rest of us are a,
okay,
it's, it is goodwill hunting,
except we're not good at it.
Math.
Oh, that's stupid fucking
movie. Jesus Christ.
He is a genius at math. And he goes
around beating the shit out of people.
When was the last time a mathlete
went around bullying people,
you know?
Okay.
And then what an accountant who can do 30
pull ups? What, what else? What I mean,
how much of a fucking leap am I supposed
to make? And these God damn movies,
you know what line I hate
the most in goodwill hunting.
I know I brought this up
before is when fucking, uh,
they're in the therapy
session and uh, you know,
he's got the hammer,
the ranch and I said I took the fucking
wrench cause you know, fuck him, right.
Um, or whatever the fucking
line is. And then they ask,
okay,
he asked Robin Williams what
he's benching and he says to 60,
yeah,
there's no way that was
written in the script.
How much power does Robin Williams
have that the director won't be like,
Hey Robin,
can you drop that number down?
A little bits of this movie can stay
remotely believable to 60. What?
After you add up benching
70 pounds, 10 times. Wait,
70 pounds. 10. That's 700.
Uh, let's, let's go back to
the book elements here. Um,
anyways, plowing ahead. Um, this is
the Monday morning podcast by the way.
And a lot of you have a lot of you
have been given me shit by the way,
cause lately they haven't been coming out.
I have a phenomenal fucking excuse that
you're going to understand in about 10
months as to why I was
late. All right. You can't,
why do you call it the
Monday morning podcast?
Because I record them on Monday mornings
except when I'm busy and I love for the
most part, I get the fucking
thing out, you know? Right.
Right now it's 10 30 Monday morning,
my time when I'm doing this fucking thing.
So it is the Monday morning
podcast and my fucking world.
Can you stop making it about yourself?
Okay.
Then every once in a while,
once in a fucking Blue Moon,
I'm so busy I can't get it done until
the Tuesday and all these fucking cons
come out of the woodwork.
Yeah.
Why aren't you glad you're working with,
yeah.
Why don't you go fucking slap your mom?
Why don't you do that a couple of
times? Forehand, backhand, forehand,
and then just fucking give it one of
those little nose twisties for being dumb
enough to not be on birth control.
All right. Advertising advice. Uh,
hey bill.
Instead of telling people to go to your
podcast page and click on the Amazon
link, tell them to go to your podcast
page, clear the cookies on their browser,
then click the amazon.com link.
As soon as they get there,
add the page to their bookmarks.
Then every time they visit amazon.com
from the bookmarks, their bookmarks,
it's the same as clicking the link on
your page without actually having to go
there. It's the fucking future,
man. That's what he wrote.
Um, yeah. If my listeners are smart
enough to do that, I don't know how,
how do you clear the cookies? How do
you do that? I don't know how to do it.
I bought a new laptop,
by the way. Everybody,
and it's the most annoying thing ever
is now. I don't know how to do anything.
You know, I, I can't fucking
do anything anymore. I want to,
I can't even figure out how to fucking,
yeah,
put a photo up to make it my screen saver.
I don't know how to do it now because
now it's completely fucking different on
the new Mac book pro,
you know,
I don't understand these fucking
computers. It's like, you know,
I go out and I buy a car. Yeah, it's a
little faster. Technology's a little,
but I still know how to drive it. Gas
Brake, put it in drive. You know this.
Not these fucking cunts. Not all
fucking Nah, no belt Magoo there.
Whatever the fuck his name is. The guy
with the new balance who finally died.
Thank God that douchebag. Oh,
we switched and everything up.
Never having the chargers fit the old
phone. All his shit going into the ocean.
You know, I love that guy. Like used to
compare themselves to Gandhi. Did Gandhi,
did he have like a sweatshop of people
jumping to their deaths because they
would make an Gandy fucking iPads.
Like I had a lot of balls, man.
You know, he really did with this
turtleneck and his salt and pepper.
Pubes I really didn't like,
uh,
been a pothead for 10 years and we
go, here we go. 20 minutes in Ben,
a pothead for 10 years. Uh, hey bill,
I'm a comedy junkie among other things
and I really appreciate your show. Well,
thank you very much. Um, it helps me
get through my commute, but up to pathy,
uh,
and the awkwardness of working in a law
firm and I just want to say I appreciate
you to show it's really a release for me.
Um,
why is it awkward working in a
law firm has that word awkward.
Just kind of lost all meeting. Is that
like the default adjective everybody goes,
everybody goes to now, Hey,
I ran into your girlfriend
the other night in the bar.
Awkward.
Why was it awkward?
It's a bar was what, what happened
in there? That was awkward.
You work in a law firm. Why is that
awkward? That sounds like a very good job.
Why am I speaking like a
robot? Um, anyways, but anyway,
I've smoked weed on and off taking year
breaks here and there since about 2001
when I was in high school. However,
when I did smoke, I smoked every day,
multiple times a day.
It really didn't affect me much until
recently. About eight years of this.
After about eight years of this,
when I turned 25 I started to notice
some slowness, physically, mentally,
and just in everything I did.
I hated it,
but I didn't want to stop smoking.
I could very well stopped easily,
but I'd always feel like
I'd be happier high.
I remember you talking about some guy who
knew who freaked out when he found out
he couldn't smoke when you
took them on a road trip.
That is a little extreme to me and I am
nowhere near that type of personality.
I'm now 26 and I'm slowly slowing down
quite a bit to just once a night if at
all. We can also get
expensive the more you smoke.
I think smoking is okay,
but if you haven't then I wouldn't
because it's sort of like beer where it
starts off as nothing and
ends up as a crutch anyways.
I just feel like if you smoke,
that's fine,
but be organized about it and make sure
it's not affecting your personality or
other types of interaction or whatever.
Honestly,
I wish I never smoked in my life because
it's so hard to look at someone's
smoking it and not want to ask for a Toke.
If anyone who smokes weed wants some
advice, mine would be moved to California.
Get a card, smoke your heart, heart out,
and find out how positive slash. Negative.
It really is. At least this way you're
doing it legally. I know, because I,
I know this because I did it not for the
weed, more for girlfriend, but I digress.
And if anyone cares, girl scout cookies.
Cookies are the shit. By the way,
if you thought I was white, I'm
not, I'm Chinese. All right.
I think it was a little high when he
wrote to us that last paragraph use by the
end of it. He's just fucking, he's
eaten cookies getting paranoid.
They think I'm white man.
Um,
okay.
Yeah, I think, well, I think
we this, it's just like,
I think a lot of ways it's like booze in
that, uh, you know, you have a beer here,
you have a beer. That's not a big deal.
But yeah, it starts consuming your life.
I mean that's a major statement. Like,
you know, I could not smoke weed,
but I just feel I would
be happier if I did. Um,
for some reason with weed,
people don't really see that as,
that's like a major red flag.
It's just not considered.
That's actually considered funny and like
logical. But like if I said, you know,
I don't have to drink,
but I just feel like my life is happier
when I do or I'd be happier if I was
drunk.
You know what I mean?
Or people will get like high before they
go in and go to work and they're kinda
like high for the first couple hours.
Like that would be like me shotgunning
a couple of beers in the parking lot.
I mean, just picture that, you know,
walking by and you see your boss,
you catch a mid, like, you know,
he's looking out of his peripheral.
Is he sucking on the side of a bud tall?
You know,
I dunno.
I think it's definitely like anything,
it can't be good to sit there and putting
all that fucking smoke in your lungs
the same way.
Uh,
okay.
I Dunno, I think he's a danger about
alcohol is when you fucking up your liver.
I don't think you really
notice until it's fucked up.
Whereas like I think if you smoke a lot
you kind of, Oh my God, I'm really winded.
This is really affected me.
I think like your liver is uh,
you only recently I started
learning about how bad,
okay,
booze man, you always hear that
cirrhosis of the liver. But I,
I mean I thought you literally had to
be walking around with a glass in your
hand all the time. And I know
a number of guys who are, uh,
you know,
dealing with that shit now and uh,
lemon put lemon in your water clears out
you fucking live. Uh, um, so what was,
what was actually your point here then?
A pothead for 10 years.
You just sharing your experience as
you rolled up another one and got super
paranoid.
MMM.
All right. Cheating whore
is a great story. Bill,
I want to thank you for helping me out
with a really hard time of my life.
MMM.
Um,
I'm 24 years old, a student at a
university and I had a girlfriend.
Could this font be any fucking,
uh, and I had a girlfriend
two years younger than me.
We were going out for seven months.
She's working at a local cafe
and about three weeks ago,
out of the fucking blue comes to me and
tells me that a regular at the cafe was
hitting on her.
Okay.
She told me that she had a boy.
She told him that she had a boyfriend
and was reassuring to me that nothing was
going on,
but we had some problems
in our relationship that we
needed to fix because she
felt good with all the flirting
and she didn't want to cheat on me.
Wait a minute.
But we had some problems
in our relationship that we
needed to fix because she
felt good with all the flirting
and she didn't want to cheat on me.
I'll say she liked this guy hitting
on him. Oh, Jesus. Anyways, he says,
I took that shit hard and I
told her I would do anything,
do anything to make her happy, even
though she knew I loved her. So I did.
I gave her all my time and energy
to make her happy. Oh, there you go.
There's a fucking recipe for misery.
Fuck all my dreams.
Let me sit here and cater to
your emotions. You can't. Um,
that was the cliff notes.
Anyways, then one week ago,
she calls me and breaks up with me,
tells me that she fucked with that
guy because she was developing strong
feelings for me and was
scared that I would hurt her.
Ah,
you got to give it up to them.
You gotta give it up. Women
are like, they're a guy has
to learn how to be a pimp.
Women just naturally know how to do it.
And I swear to God,
it all comes down to the fact that
they can't beat the shit out of us.
The fact that we could beat the living
shit out of a woman is what kills us in
an argument.
Because you're taking solace in
something that you're never going to do.
You know, it's this card you
never gonna play, hopefully,
unless you're a fucking animal.
Um,
meanwhile they are developing themselves
mentally and figuring out how you work
psychologically.
And they're just like,
I really think once you're in or where
I'm sharing a real like relationship. Um,
just to make it fair to help the guy,
I think like three days a week,
or at least during the arguments,
like the second the argument starts,
the woman should always have on like
tearaway clothes and she pulls him off and
then she's immediately dressed
like Hannibal Lecter. You know,
that ice cream man outfit that he had,
you know, has her hair slicked back seat.
Just really know what you're fucking with.
That is brilliant.
Can you imagine trying to say
that to your girl? Listen,
I fucked this hottie at work,
but it's only because I care about you
so much and I was worried that you were
going to hurt me because my
love for you is so deep. Jesus.
You know what?
I think I would high fiber.
I'd high five on knock a couple
of her fucking press on nails off.
That was a good one. So anyways, he
goes, I know it's fucking retarded.
I lost my mind. I went to the cafe
and I beat the shit out of that guy.
Wow.
Mainly because if I didn't,
I was going to beat her
and she didn't deserve
to find any excuse
what?
Mainly because if I didn't that was going
to beat her and she didn't deserve to
find any excuse.
And because he was wasn't a
hole for hitting on a girl
who was in a relationship.
Um, yeah dude, I don't know about
that. I don't know about that.
He's doing what a guy does. A guy goes
around and tries to fuck women. Okay.
He's not in a relationship with her and
he's certainly not in a relationship
with you. The person who was wrong
in that is the woman you know.
Now fat guy knows you or you came down to,
he gave him a warning,
you know, came down with you, Clint
Eastwood Eyes All squinting up.
Stay away from her. You know you
did one of those and then he didn't,
then that's on him,
but you just come out of nowhere.
Can you please elaborate on that?
Like what was he doing?
Yeah.
Was he down at the
restaurant? Like, you know,
making a fucking egg over easy and
all of a sudden you came back and
did you beat him down the street?
Like fucking a sunny and the Godfather?
Did he need you to throw in into some
like trashed bill trashcan lid or
something like that? Like one
of those fucking, the whole,
Oh God damn fucking neighborhood season.
Um,
I actually respected in a way,
but you shouldn't do it because then
you get sued and then she actually feels
like she's right. See,
I knew he was crazy. Um,
now the bitch is blaming me for
making a scene. Oh, there it is.
And because her boss, her boss is
look at her and think she is a whore.
If she,
if she didn't,
if she didn't thought about that, if
she didn't think about the consequences,
why should I was,
was I in the wrong?
I don't want to regret what I
did because she deserved it.
All I did was lover and she slept with
another guy at fucking hurts, man.
It really does. I can't move on. Thank
you for hearing me out. All right.
You know what,
um,
when I said you shouldn't have beat the
beat the guy up that that was for you,
that had nothing to do with her.
I just don't want you to get
sued or go to jail or uh,
you know, you know, you get
a fucking record. I mean,
dude, you're, you're, you're,
you're,
you made a move there that could
alter your future and believe me,
dude,
this is a great thing about horse
is when you really did this,
I mean,
this is going to hurt like hell,
but there's going to be a moment where
you're going to find this fucking
hilarious.
You really got to believe me on this one.
At some point you're going to be talking
about it out loud to your friends and
you're just going to say the
situation out loud that you were in
and
there'll be enough time has gone by that
your feelings for this girl have faded
and it's almost like it's somebody else
and you're going to laugh at yourself
and then you're going to laugh
at the whole fucking thing
and
it's probably going to hit that. It
was that, why did I risk going to jail?
Maybe you know,
I don't have,
I have like a felony or something
like that on your record.
Like this isn't the mother your kids.
All right,
you can't trust this girl as far as
you can fucking throw her. You know,
you can't as far as you could fucking
pick her up by the back of her fucking g
string and the scruff of that awful
tattoo on the back of her neck that she,
if she doesn't have it, she's going to
get at some point and you can't trust her.
You can't trust her.
So you just got to get to the
bullshit and you're going to be fine.
But in the future, dude, I would not
go. I mean you just basically, uh,
you like the transporter
for real. You just, you did,
you did like the movie version of what
everybody wants to do in that situation,
but you did it for real and you
somehow got away with it. Uh,
did you split your fucking slacks when
you threw that high kick to his fucking
cheap bone?
I just read that recently.
I read an article about that guy
is Jason stayed them. How uh,
he has to have special pants on because
he can kick his leg so fucking high.
You can't do that in a suit
without ripping. Now, if I
was directing the movie,
I would be like,
dude,
that's going to make this fucking movie
so much better that if you're standing
there and some Anderson little suit
and you're kicking so much ass,
your slacks a literally
disintegrating off your fucking legs.
How funny would that be? Then? He's
standing there in the end, his fucking,
his slacks are looking like, you
know, the hulks pants, right.
Bill Bixby his pants after
he turns into the hulk.
Okay.
There are, that's that, that would
be the funniest fucking thing ever.
I don't know, but it will be all
like the INSEAM and the crotch.
But like down by the bottom off, I would
totally have it. I'd be like, dude,
we got to do this with real slacks and
you have to wear knee high black socks
with fucking sock. Garters just like,
we'll just do one like this. Jason,
can we just do one like this? Um,
yeah, dude, you, you did that.
You went the real deal on this. So, uh,
luckily you got away with it.
Um,
and I think it's great that everybody
knows that she's a fucking whore and do it
just affected,
look it,
she fucked around and immediately
tried to put the guilt on you.
Then you went down there and beat the
shit out of that guy because she's a whore
and now she's coming back at you
once again, blaming you. So this,
this was would have been the, the, uh,
the cycle that you would, you would've
had if you, if you decided to, uh,
share your life with this person,
they would constantly be hurting you.
And then blaming you saying that you were
the reason and I swear to God and you
want to fucking awful says guys out
there and relationships like that.
Just allowing these women to
do shit like this. You know,
but it's never talked about on TV because
it's considered misogynistic because
it's not every woman doing it.
It's not every woman.
That's just the select few.
Yeah know.
So we're the guys who beat the shit
out of women. Those are a select few.
Doesn't stop you from talking
about it, nor should it. All right,
there are hypothetical talk show hosts
that I'm, I'm sitting across from.
Um, all right, let's do some
advertising. Everybody. Hey, you ready?
Are you ready for some advertising?
Sit on down.
Everybody get out of fucking pencil.
What the hell is it?
I'm the God damn worst.
I had this whole fucking thing set up.
There it is. All right.
Hey everybody, stamps.com.
I think you got this one memorized
at this point, but I got to tell you,
I have new listeners
every week. Um, you know,
last week I was in,
uh,
my podcast actually was
quoted in a set a fucking ant.
What the fuck is that? I never know if
I got to see, I just want, I want to do,
I want to learn more about insects.
Now do I kill this one?
And then that means I have more insects
because this thing is eating the other
ones.
It's like a miniature lady Bug lady.
Um,
you know,
last week my podcast was actually
quoted in featured in Star magazine.
So there you go. All right, so I
know I have some new listeners.
All right, so here's the advertising. Um,
once again from the
wonderful people@stamps.com,
everybody hold onto your hats.
They're about ready to make your life a
whole lot easier. Um, what do we got here?
Stamps dot comments.
It's so easy and so convenient.
You can print official us postage
using your own computer and printer.
I know that because I do,
that is how I send out all my DVDs.
Everybody every damn weekend when I'm
going to go out the week before I got my
DVDs, I put on my little's little visor.
I got my little scale, bing, Bang,
boom. I can do it whenever I want.
24, seven, whenever I want to.
There's no more going. Oh Damn it.
I should've gone to the post office.
The post office is always open
because it's in your apartment. Um,
anyways,
this is the deal right now.
You go to stamps.com they have a special
offer from my listeners, my followers,
uh,
my cult.
Use My last name bur bur for a no risk
trial plus a $110 bonus offer that
includes a digital scale and
up to $55 in free postage.
All right? Can't be,
can't loose. Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything
else, I don't care if your baby's crying.
Click on the radio microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in burpee you
are are that stamps,
stamps.com enter bur and you know you
don't have to go to the post office
anymore for the rest of your life.
You can cut that out.
You know when you finally have a day
off from work, right? You get it.
You don't have to go anymore.
It's phenomenal.
I'm waiting for dmv.com that's what I'm
waiting for. I know they have a website.
I can't figure it out.
All right,
which once again shows you how awesome
stamps.com is because I could actually
figure it out and I'm a moron.
There you go. All right,
friends. Hoar problem cheating, whore
friends. A lot of horse stuff this week.
You know, if I was into
this stats, the lovely Nia,
everybody, where are you going?
Oh, you going to go work out? All right,
I'll see you later. Bringing the dog down.
What's up puppy? What's that puppy? Oh,
Bojangles.
You know what's great about a pit bulls?
You can really throw them
around, you know? That's right.
I was hanging out at a friend's house and
he had this little cute little dog and
I swear to God, this thing must
have weighed like two pounds.
I was like afraid to touch
it after messing with this
thing my dogs made out of
titanium. Dude, you
smell, you need a bath,
you know. Hey codependent, why
don't you go lay down over there?
All right and don't step on my
book about the elements. Clia.
Lay down,
lay down.
Why do they always get a walk around for
like 20 seconds in a circle before they
figure out how they're going to lie
down once the deal, uh, friends.
Hoar problem.
Mr. Brewer,
I love the podcast and would really
appreciate some advice regarding my best
friend in me. Uh, okay,
let's try and guess what this is going.
Either your best friend is dating a
whore or your best friend is a whore.
If your best friend is a whore,
why wouldn't you want to fuck her?
Why don't I just read it?
All right.
Let me start with some
background information.
My best friend and I have known
each other since I can remember,
but recently I'm almost at the point of
losing contact with him because he acts
like a fucking idiot over some douchebag.
Girl.
He's never been a ladies man.
So He's been on and off with this one,
this one client for quite a while.
Oh yeah.
He's hanging onto it and he's hanging
onto it. That's what he's doing. Yup.
He's afraid of, no one's not going to
come along and he's clinging to that.
That one piece like dead, uh, like
Leonardo at the end of a titanic.
Um,
and he's going to have the same fate.
And this girl always used to have a
boyfriend, always has to have a boyfriend,
cheats on them all the time, not
exaggerating, high school dropout.
And she loves any drama she can get.
Jesus Christ,
she loves any drama she can get
her grimy, come covered. Hands on.
I hate this whore very much. Yeah. In
case we didn't understand that with Hulu.
First six sentences,
uh,
there are not enough adjectives in the
dictionary or synonyms in the fucking
thesaurus to describe this piece of shit.
So now to the story,
a couple of months ago,
she dumped her boyfriend and a day
later started dating my best friend.
Nobody in our group of friends liked
her and she always acted like she was
miserable while dating my friend,
weeks after them dating,
uh, the old cum dumpster is pregnant. Oh,
get a paternity test immediately
get one of them little Swaby swabs.
Uh, he came anyways, he came
inside. All right, dude. Jesus,
we get it.
All right.
He based, let me, let me
try and clean this up. Uh,
he had unprotected sex with
there are to completion
because she told him it's almost
impossible for her to get pregnant.
My friend is an idiot
for falling for that.
So instantly he jumped into marrying
this girl it at the age of 19 and dating
only three or four weeks.
What the fuck?
She went to the doctor and they told her
she had been pregnant almost two weeks
prior to him busting insider and how she
and how she acted. She knew this.
I don't know how she was acting.
She knew this the whole time.
Also,
the boyfriend before my friend posted
inside our many times don't if it
obviously,
so lo and behold,
this slot runs to her
ex because he's the dad.
So she got the drama. She want
it now. Well that's good then.
So this kid is not getting stuck with
the kid. Now, several months later,
my friend is back to talking to this
girl and this is where I'm pissed off
beyond belief. He still somehow
likes this girl that played him,
acted like a complete bitch while dating
him and cheated on him while dating.
He thinks the kid might be his
and also said if it is his,
he would get back together with her.
So the advice I'm asking is,
so the advice to you guys, come on
man, do a little a proofread here.
So the,
the advice I'm asking for is how do I
tell my friend to quit talking to this
pathetic human being and quit being and
Douche about thinking about that baby
might be his one.
Obviously it's not,
and move on with his life because that
girl will never be happy and never
stopped being a cunt.
I've tried to tell him to not talk to
her and if she wants a paternity test,
uh, when it's born to take care
of the whole thing. But Bob,
I don't even need to read the
rest of this. Thanks. Just to bar.
I really appreciate your vice and how
to get him to stop being a Douche.
You can't help him. You
can't help this kid. I mean,
these aren't little drama moments.
This is the biggest drama
you could possibly have at
19 when it comes to dating.
All right? And um, you would think that
after he went through the, Oh my God,
she's pregnant and then found
out it was somebody else's,
that he wouldn't keep coming back.
This dude has major fucking problems.
He needs to go see a therapist.
It's not on you. All right,
it's not on you.
What are you going to do?
You're going to jump in the car with them
and try and grab the wheel from him as
he pulls back and takes you over
the cliff with him. Fuck it.
It's not your problem. It's the good
fellas moment. He's content to be a jerk.
Let them be a jerk. It's
out of your hands. You know?
And if you don't want to look at it,
I would just stop hanging out with them.
What do you, what are you supposed
to do? What are you spot everybody,
you know something,
I hate to say this for the most part,
everybody has one guy
like that and their crew,
there's always one guy who going to marry
the whore and find out 15 years later
that it's not his kid.
And you know,
and there's going to be one person in
your crew that's going to try and tell
them that and the kid's going to
flip out and not talk to him at all.
And that 15 years later they'll run into
each other in a bar and be like, hey,
you will kinda, you kinda right. So
what do you got dope.
I mean, what the fuck more does
this kid need? He's an idiot.
That kid is an idiot, you know,
so he might as well Marian idiot.
Cause that cancels both of them out and
it saves a decent human being on both
sides,
you know?
Okay.
I,
I don't know what to tell you.
He's just psyched if anybody will
fuck him regardless of the situation.
And she's a horse so she knows she, you
know, she's fucking his brains out. So
yeah,
I really don't have anything funny
to say about that. That's just,
that's fucking awful.
It's got to suck for you because
that's your friend. But a,
you know,
you're going to lose some friends in life.
I got to tell you, there's, there's,
there's a number of different
ways you lose friends in life. Uh,
you know,
the awful ways they die or a,
you fuck around with their women or
they fuck around with your women.
Uh, there's the, you're dating someone
who's doing shit like this person.
And then there's the
other ones where you know,
you start doing well in
life and they're not,
and then they resent you
or the other way around.
Maybe you're the resentful concept,
but you're gonna lose some friends.
So you lost one cause you're not going
to be able to hang out with this kid
anymore. Um, I dunno.
Just, I don't know what to tell you, dude.
You fuck where the fuck is his dad?
Where's his mom?
Where are the people like
advising this kid? Jesus Christ.
I would fucking lock that kid up in the,
in the room room above the garage,
like a heroin addict and I just keep
giving them chicken noodle soup until he
got over this fucking chick. Um, I dunno.
Jesus. I hope this one's
fucking upbeat. Shitty uncle.
I'm shitty uncle. Hey belt. I'm a lady
listener. And before I jump into it here,
I just want to say that
as a female listener,
I don't have a problem with any
of your women trashing. Hey,
nice to see someone has a sense of humor.
Uh,
I think the only women that get offended
or insulted by what you talk about are
the ones who can relate to or feel they
reflect in some way what you're talking
about. Ah, sometimes. And then sometimes
I am a moron, but I appreciate you, uh,
actually seeing that. Um, anyways,
maybe you're talking about
the gold digging whores or
just overall annoyance of
women.
Clearly that's not all women,
but ones who send you shitty feel like
you're speaking of them because they are
like that. Fuck them. Fuck them. I think
it's hilarious. Absolutely ridiculous.
When one listener out a thousand takes
one thing you talk about and tries to
make it personal. What a
bunch of cons. You know what,
this weekend when I did my
show and I closed with my
gold digging whores bit, uh,
I was selling DVDs afterwards,
you know, whoring myself out,
showing a little bit of leg as I
do. And um, this couple came up in,
the woman paid in, some other woman
yelled, yelled as she walked by. Yeah.
You saw who just pay,
you saw just paid.
And I used to take the bait
on that and I just laughed.
I just laughed and it warms my heart
knowing that I annoyed the shit out of her
with my closing. 10 minute gold digging
whore bit. Um, so anyways, here we go.
So here's the family problem.
I appreciate your perspective on,
I've got this absolute absolute asshole.
Have an uncle,
he's a recovered alcoholic who's
landed him self, a wife with money.
Jesus, the guy's been a con
man since I can remember.
It's just that now he's a sober con man.
Yeah,
I really don't like addicts generally
speaking, generally speaking,
that some of the most
selfish motherfuckers on the
planet and they do some of
the most inconsiderate shit
that you could possibly do.
And anytime you call them on it,
they always say science.
She's got a lot of shit
coming out now and they just,
a lot of stuff is coming up. Uh, I dunno,
I probably get some fucking
letters on that. Emails.
No one writes letters anymore. So anyways,
uh, he's always been a fucking annoying,
fucking annoying, an arrogant. But
recently he fucked my parents for money.
My parents felt heartbroken
and betrayed over this.
I've always hated him and hate him even
more now that he made my mother cry.
It made my father angry in order
to stay in my father's good graces.
He threw my mother and I under the bus
in an email to my dad one day saying
everything was our fault.
I was glad when my father finally told
them off and it said not to contact me or
my mother again. Well, here's my question.
How the fuck did you know that
he was a piece of shit con man,
before they did a few weeks ago,
I had to go to my grandfather's birthday.
My mom and dad couldn't make it,
so my boyfriend and I went alone.
I didn't acknowledge my uncle when I
said hi to everyone and kept my distance
throughout the day.
He kept interrupting any conversation I
was having with other relatives to make
an obnoxious joke about me or Philly.
I live in Philly and love it.
My uncle is from Philly, but lives in New
York and now is all about it. Yankees,
cheesecake and all, uh, he
trashes Philly all the time,
which pisses me off because
he knows I like it there.
He even went up to my boyfriend who
was wearing an eagle's hat and started
talking shit to him. Um, she goes, yeah,
I know that might be justified there.
Um,
everything he did was
rude and disrespectful.
He never said hello or asked
about my mom and dad when I left.
I was angry for days and he didn't
say anything to him or call him out.
So my question to you, bill it, should
I say something to my shitty uncle next
time he's always been a loud mouth son
of a bitch, but, uh, now it's a personal,
but now it's personal and fucking
rude that he continues to do it.
When he knows I know all this shit,
sometimes they think he still looks at
me as this little girl, Nice Blah, blah.
I don't need to read any more of this.
What do you think any words of
wisdom would help love the podcast?
Thanks in advance?
Well,
what you should have said was you should
have announced to the entire Party.
My uncle is being rude to me because
he fucked my parents out of money.
Just something, just throw his fucking
throw his dirty laundry right out there.
Just say,
why are you being rude to me?
Why you deliberately being rude to me
right now? I don't know. Just weird.
You can't like call him like a
piece of shit. Um, I don't know.
But he won because he made you
angry and he ruined your day.
Why don't you just be condescending to
them where every time he talks to me like,
aw, you're adorable. Hey, who'd
you fuck over today? You know,
I heard they have an old folks home down
the street. They like playing checkers.
Maybe you can play some checkers,
a tinny little tiddlywinks with them
and steal their money. You know,
just do shit like that.
A good joke from the alcoholic over here.
Everybody.
I would just do stuff like that. Just
throw his shit right in his face. No,
you know what you do is you say all his
shippy just be really nice. Oh my God,
my uncle,
my favorite relative who's an alcoholic.
I got to tell you people,
out of all the people who have
stolen money from my parents,
this guy here is my favorite.
Just do shit like that.
You just keep complimenting and as you're
calling them an absolute piece of shit
who can't handle their booze.
I still love you. Anyways,
I just started drinking a beer right
in front of them. Ah, God damn it.
Is that delicious? Hey, you want one?
C'Mon. You know you do. Oh, that's right.
You can't handle it. Who's little
baby? Then you just pinch his fat.
Fucking booze cheeks. Just I,
I would do too. Shit like that.
Just annoy him back.
But don't sit there in silence and let
this guy fucking do that to you. You know,
fucking these levels too.
God Damn Low. Too Low.
Hello? Hello. You know I,
I rented that movie to kill a mockingbird.
I finally watched that movie and I gotta
be honest with you. I don't get it.
I don't get that movie.
Who's supposed to be the mockingbird
in that? Cause the way I look at it,
they killed the mockingbird,
you know,
but then in the end they act like a Robert
Duvall character is the mockingbird.
He might be another one, but wasn't
the guy who was on trial a mockingbird.
How come they didn't give a
fuck about and I don't buy that.
He just ran away and then they shot him.
I think that that was that racist shit
where they just decided that they were
going to kill him. So then they
just made up that he ran away.
So this is what I like to do,
people to close out the podcast.
I like to bring up a movie that came out,
oh 60 70 fucking years ago.
And uh,
talk about it like it came out like
fucking six months ago. Oh Jesus.
I'm sorry. Let's, let's, let's,
let's finish up here with,
with a one last little advertisement.
Uh, game slide.com everybody,
is that what it's called? I hope it
is advertising schedule. Here we go.
Here we go. Came, fly.com everybody,
if you like playing video games,
wouldn't be wonderful to
have 8,000 video games,
8,000 video games at your fingertips
that can be delivered to your door or
directly to your PC.
All right, for 15 days,
you get a free trial,
a 15 day free trial.
That is a two weeks and one day where
you can access all 8,000 of those games
for absolutely free. Just go to
[inaudible] dot com slash bill burr,
uh, click on the microphone and all that
stuff and you'll, you'll, you'll be good.
You will be good to go.
8,000 video games.
Look at me,
you know,
bring the post office into
your apartment, uh, the Games,
oh,
I don't even what I'm saying anymore than
I do the amazon.com yet that I kind of
do that.
You guys know the deal at this point.
You want to help my podcast and give 10%
of what I make to the wounded warriors
project. Just go to billboard.com, click
on the podcast, and then in the, uh,
the corner,
you'll see the Amazon banner.
You Click on that and then then just buy
whatever you want to buy on amazon.com.
They kicked me a percentage and then 10%
of that I give to the wounded warriors
project. Um, and that's it.
That's it. That's a podcast for this
week. Everybody. How about those Celtics?
You know, I actually tried to
watch a red sox game yesterday.
I watched a, I don't even know
anybody on the team anymore. You know,
I finally saw what that Gonzales guy look
like. There'll be got from the Padres.
I haven't watched in, um, I
dunno. Good couple of years.
Whose June of something,
oh nine or 2010.
That's when I just said, you
know what? Fuck this. I can't
watch this shit anymore,
Bob.
I just root for them to lose cause
I want Bobby Valentine to get fired.
Although I do think it's funny that he
tipped his cap when everyone was born.
Them. I do think that that's
funny, but I hate when people, um,
just cause controversy and just make
shit about themselves when they haven't
accomplished anything. Then I
just described my podcast. Um,
all right. Maybe on the Bobby Valentine
of podcasting. I think you are.
I think you are that fucking annoying.
Uh, that's the podcast for this week.
Everybody.
Uh,
where am I going to be coming up?
Why don't,
why don't I go to bill bird.com and
we'll see what's, uh, what the deal is.
Hey, can anybody tell me why dog
sleeps so fucking much? They'll put it,
they won't,
they'll put in eight hours and then you
take them around the block and then they
sleep for like another four hours and
they get all antsy around noontime.
You take them out again and then they
just plopped down and then they have one
more burst of energy and then they're
ready to sleep for another eight hours.
Isn't that what,
like all wild animals do like
don't like lines for the most part.
Just laying around all day,
you know,
and I guess he got to go kill something
and they go and they kill something.
They fucking gorge themselves and they
just lay around in the sun for like the
next three Aa sleeping.
Isn't that what they do?
You know somebody down the street.
I have to whisper because somebody
down the street, they, uh,
they bought two giant lions,
um,
to have outside the house.
You know, like the fake lions.
It basically, it just screams
new money. You know what I mean?
That's like one of the,
one of the first things you do,
like the avid shithead who hits the
lottery, you know what they're gonna do,
right? They're going to get a limo, go
boobs, and they're going to buy a car,
maybe pay off one bill.
Right?
And then the very next thing they're
gonna do is they're going to buy two giant
fucking lions to stand guard at the
end of the driveway of their fucking
apartment building.
I don't know why people do that,
but these ones were actually decent.
They were actually decent looking. Um,
all right, here's the
upcoming events. I have a,
my next row gig isn't until June
15th. He fucking serious. Juge Oh,
I guess I'll be in La,
building up my act, uh,
the San Jose Improv on
June 15th and June 16th.
And on the 17th, it says San Jose
Improv, but we got to fix that.
I'm actually going to be at the, uh,
Chicago theater with Steve Byrne,
Vince Vaughn and all these other guys.
I don't know who else
is going to be there,
but that's enough of a show right there,
isn't it? June 17th the Chicago theater.
Um,
oh and June 15th and 16th,
I'll also be performing with a
Chelsea Peretti Sacramento zone.
Chelsea Peretti. So, you know,
she's psyched to get up there.
That's why she's doing the Gig.
You know,
she wants to drive and go see
family up in northern California.
Um, Ontario Improv. I played June 29th,
30th and July 1st Hampton beach
ballroom casino going white trash here,
people July 14th.
Then I go to the new Newport yachting
center July 15th and I know what you're
thinking there. Oh, is that the
Illuminati comedy club? No, it is not.
It's a parking lot with a tent over it.
And I'll be performing.
There was some sort of
makeshift air conditioner,
pathetically trying to blow
cold air on my giant forehead.
And then my triumphant retort
returned to New York City, July 26th,
27th,
28th and 29th at on Broadway
in New York,
New York.
Then we're into September and football
season and I'm going to be doing cities
that I have never done before.
Like Orlando Eight, ninth,
seventh, eighth and ninth.
Look at that. Orlando,
Florida. Um, that's it.
That's the podcast for this
week. Go fuck yourselves. Um,
thank you to everybody who's been
listening. The podcast has been growing.
Thanks everybody has been going on to
amazon.com game, fly.com and stamps,
stamps.com uh,
appreciate it.
I don't know when I'll ever see
any money from any of these things.
It's amazing how this advertising works.
You know the advertise and then
like nine months later they,
they finally send you a check,
you know.
Thank you for your wonderful work
hyping the new palm pilot back in 2001.
Um, all right. That's it.
Is there anything that they,
any shit I wanted to talk
about any sports? Um,
hey bill, who do you like for
the fucking Nba Championship?
Anybody but the Lakers?
Anybody but the Lakers,
uh, who do I like for the Stanley Cup? Um,
I like a lot of the teams. I like a lot
of teams that are playing each other.
Like I like, uh, I sort of like
the capital's, I liked the rangers.
I like the flyers.
I don't like the devils.
I'll never get over that boring style
of play that got them three Stanley cups
that left wing Loc trap defense during
the clutch and grab error made me almost
abandoned the game.
And for some reason I blame them when I
know people played that for years. Um,
so I can't get into them. Um, although I
do think it's funny that they went, oh,
Stanley cups right across the
river from fucking New York.
That does make me laugh. So in a
pinch, if I had to vote, vote, vote,
vote for either, uh, that was
vote or in route at the same time,
if I had to vote for a
Jersey or the rangers,
that's a tough one range.
Is it just such a legendary club,
even though they haven't, they've won
won Stanley Cup and 72 fucking years. Uh,
I still like him though.
I like the fly is I'd like to see the St
Louis Blues and I would say I'd like to
see the La Kings if they're fucking fans,
weren't also Laker fans.
You know, I just, I don't
know. I'm so fucking sick, you
know, you know, depressing.
It was to go back to
Boston and run into the,
the fucking morons that I did for
the most part am I met nice people,
but just a couple of those.
It was just so fucking depressing because
I loved going back to Boston because
as far as a sports fan,
I've been,
I've been behind enemy lines since when
I left in 1995 I went to New York City
and I live in La. So I haven't had
to deal with Yankee fans, jets, fans,
and now Laker fans. And I just want
to go to a place where can I can,
I can express affection for my teams and
not have to immediately get into some
sort of fucking debate.
And then I go back there and then it's,
it's just that Shit,
you know?
And I know now that I admitted that
those things happened in Boston.
Now I'm going to get a bunch of holier
than thou fucking emails from people,
but you have to understand that I've
traveled for 20 years as a comedian,
and I've done the third
show Saturday night and a,
and I've talked to those people.
So I bring it,
do you want to fucking talk down to me?
Why am I defending box? I can't defend it.
I can't defend it, but you know, I dunno.
I don't know what the fuck I'm saying.
All right, that's the podcasts.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I'll talk to you next week.